although maybe Erwin's would get to all
be together on a family honeymoon it's
just so great here's Robert what's it
been like to be on on bindi and
Chandler's honeymoon so I knew where
they were going going pretty cool spot
so I was you know trying to maybe see if
I could tag along but yeah that idea was
we're not gonna get through but it is
nice to be in Chandler just such hard
work is above anything else you know
like we're going through a crazy time at
the zoo as everyone is and they just
stepped up and decided to clean out well
teri you're here on the honeymoon and I
just learned that you gave the green
light for them to even start talking in
the first place years ago so I came in
bindi was giving tours and I'm gonna
video leave this girl's really special
so I reached out to Fendi through my
brother actually writing a note to
Australian zoo and Terry's saying okay I
really had a great time on the tour
would it be okay how does this feel for
you to have this full circle moment and
what made you know back then okay I want
to allow this so out of the box to have
your brother
contact the girl's mother to ask
permission you can stay in touch because
he was in Florida so it was fairly safe
you know it's kind of hard for anything
untoward to happen on email so it was
absolutely wonderful that you know as a
family we got to know Chandler and he's
so wonderful and we ended up dragging
him along on some adventures if we were
in America we
shop with him and met his family and
just wonderful people from Florida and
real wildlife minded people and it's
just was wonderful so we kind of all
became friends and and then when things
started getting romantic I was the
unexpected it was I remember we were all
Robert you used to be like this
paleontologist in the making so we were
I think we all met up in Drumheller
Canada you know oh look the dinosaur yes
and we were staying this little
bed-and-breakfast and so the three of us
were in one room and Chandler was in the
other we're all saying goodnight and
Chandler said it's such a beautiful moon
tonight I'm gonna go look at the moon
and bindi goes that sounds great have
fun
teenage boys don't go look at the moon
clearly that was an invitation
how many people can say that but I know
you guys have talked a little bit about
how there are actually a lot of
similarities between bindi and
Chandler's love story and Steven Terry's
right dee dee can you tell me a little
more about that Terry and Mindy
[Music]
great message to the world that as we
heal stories are happening okay I know
Robert are you next to Marianna mocking
you down the aisle
today he was it was probably the the
greatest honor and the most special
moment of my life
you guys did such an amazing job of
having so many special nods through the
whole wedding and I gotta ask who's more
emotional the bride bindi or her brother
Robert it just felt like one of those
times where
yeah you just just hits you and that was
definitely one of those times I was just
hit with that kind of massive wall of
emotion and I think it was it was a
combination of a lot of different things
I think of course it's such a big moment
when my sister's getting into huge David
I honestly couldn't have been happier
so I'm happy that that she found someone
like Shambo I was just overwhelmed with
joy and you know of course there's also
that other side that I think to me
walking me down the aisle and having
that job in particular maybe you think a
lot about to happen which more than
anything you know that he could be there
on the day and I mean even now it's it's
so very passionately been just talking
about it but you know I think it was
such a beautiful day and I was yeah
pretty over time how did you feel I
can't imagine how it felt to plan this
wedding to watch your daughter walk down
the aisle watch her brother cry about it
and of course I know you guys are
feeling Steve's presence with you how
was this whole emotional day for you it
was absolutely overwhelming I think the
circumstances although everyone has
their wedding story that was affected by
the condemning it was amazing to
persevere because it was just challenge
after challenge and I felt so focused on
making sure this would happen that I
know the night before the wedding we
were all on the phone saying how could
this come together tomorrow it's got to
happen tomorrow and I felt like I had to
be the one that said well we'll make it
happen in the okay no matter what and I
don't really know how it happened
but by the time the day came around I
was just like the person who was going
to make sure everything happened
was there a moment when when you really
got emotional without it being just
trying to push through when you allowed
yourself to really feel that I think we
all did you know and the biggest
overriding feeling was that Steve wasn't
there and we wished so much that he
could have been there because so proud
but it was and to always remember that
loved ones who have mostly sweet but and
I think that it with it was one of those
things where like like mom said you you
just so focused on making sure
everything's perfect it's so busy and
getting everything sorted out and then
on the day itself when it you know when
they're saying their vows and they're
walking down the aisle and it's actually
happening in front of your eyes that's
when it you will just go oh it's
happening Wow and it just very knowing
Steve what do you think he would have
been like on the on the wedding day if
he was able to be there Terry would he
have wanted to do everything what do
you've hit the dance floor would he have
walked Mindy down the aisle and
officiated what would he have been like
he would have tackled the helicopter out
of the sky it would have cried more than
Robert and he probably would have built
a chapel in an hour
for the wedding too you know I don't
know what
the word is in the English language for
the opposite of a procrastinator but
that was Steve he was a do it now just
fix it kind of guy and he was exhausting
but the best adventure of your life and
anyone who knew Steve would say that but
very emotional very tough on the outside
and on the inside and Robert was
[Music]
throughout the rest of your life because
what you saw was truly dad in life so
how incredibly special that our lives we
captured on camera until it kinda gets
to know who dad was him as a person but
watching those documentaries it's just
it's really really special and and not
many people have not bindi and and
Chandler what about you in terms of one
moment that you think will stick out to
you I think there's something really
special and saying the most hectic and
crazy time in our lives is also the
happiest moment I think it shows that
you can get through everything whether
it's a global pandemic losing a loved
one you can always get through it and
find happiness at anything so I think
looking down the aisle for forgiveness
so I think it was just really
overwhelming we hate it
finally came together it's weird I've
never heard swear he doesn't drink he's
perfect my moment I have to send you
this photograph because I only just
discovered we were all in the big studio
yeah and we were sort of hectically tiny
figure out where to go and what to do
with flowers and how to make it look
like a wedding stuff then I just took a
minute and sat on this chair in the
corner and so I was just sitting in the
corner on my chair I'm going crazy
what we do whenever I get stressed out
it's gonna be so special the Wellness so
bright and shiny everything will be good
and in that moment one of our lovely
team members snap smile and I love it so
much
Here I am just like oh the world is
falling down around me but they were
there just from I love that so much
because it's Ernie so don't be so hard
to find happy to have people who follow
us and support us around us always
because you know generating the hottest
times in your life Rosina people to us
and the management that the meaning of
life is unconditional love
[Music]